uh we are now getting the expert um uh
testimony
of the um
not smartest son of the former president
donald trump i'm talking about eric
trump eric trump went on fox news's
hannity program to try to defend his dad
and attack joe biden on the topic of
ukraine and now at this point
it sort of seems pointless in the sense
that joe biden has an almost 60 percent
approval on his handling of ukraine
which in a country as polarized as the
united states
when 60 percent of the country believes
you're doing a good job
that's pretty overwhelming sadly in this
polarized state of affairs trump never
had 60 approval on anything that he
oversaw while he was president and they
clearly know it they're trying to run
interference for trump but remember
trump withheld military aid to ukraine
hoping it would force zelenski to start
providing dirt on joe biden
thanks to that little strategy being
outed trump ultimately had to release
the military aid to ukraine so anyway um
eric trump talks to sean hannity and
it's all completely crazy it's a
delusional fantasy world understanding
of how trump and foreign policy
coexisted and this is the trumpian sort
of analysis that counts as analysis in
their world in in which they live
listen my father would you know call up
and he would have said vladimir don't
even think about it don't even try us
i'm telling you it's not gonna work out
very well for you right so this is the
idea that trump was really really tough
on putin and that putin respected trump
now you can say a lot of things about
putin i don't think he really cares
about the welfare of individual russians
he cares about
you know furthering his plans for a sort
of new ussr and that's his priority uh
putin's ruthless and brutal he
disappears uh dissidents he disappears
slash you know disappears and by that i
mean kills and sometimes unjustly
imprisons
media people who don't agree you could
say all that stuff about putin but putin
is way smarter than trump there's no
doubt about that and there is no way in
hell that putin was intimidated in any
way by donald trump let's go to the next
clip by the way my father had a great
relationship with putin we know all the
while he's sending thousands of javelin
missiles to the ukraine is that really
me by the way
they still are on the ukraine i mean
biden has no relationship with putin and
he's literally sending blankets to
ukraine it's
you know again sean it's so these are of
course lies
uh biden and the us has uh have sent
significant military aid to ukraine
remember that the aid eric trump is
referring to his dad sending was aid
that trump initially withheld
because he was trying to push zolensky
to announce that they were investigating
joe and hunter biden he ultimately
released the aid but again importantly
a good relationship with putin comes
when putin sees
that you're a joke when putin sees that
you're a patsy and that's exactly what
putin saw in donald trump
here's one last clip of eric trump's
incisive and principled analysis of
geopolitics why
well listen putin was in with the kgb he
can read people and he could tell that
donald trump was a very strong person
right right no wrong
and again 90 of that sentence is right
putin was in the kgb
putin can read people and he can tell
that donald trump was a very
weak person i mean remember trump coming
out in helsinki and saying listen i
asked him did you hack us did you hack
the us
and he said no and he said it very
strongly and i believe him that's what
putin saw in trump trump as a patsy so
nobody ever said eric was the smart one
but now just
obviously i mean just laughably
unbelievable claims about trump's
handling of geopolitics foreign
relations russia and ukraine
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that i
want every day i don't always have time
to get exactly what i want from the
foods i'm eating but that's why athletic
greens ag-1 is so great it's a solution
that gives you everything in one scoop
and you get 75 high-quality vitamins and
minerals as well as probiotics so it
supports gut health it is one of the
great sort of add-ons to having proper
balanced nutrition
athletic greens ag-1 has become a
regular part of my day i'll put it in a
smoothie it tastes great sometimes i'll
just drink it by itself and it's been a
really great and convenient way to get
everything i would get from a
multivitamin and minerals and probiotics
that i might otherwise take separately
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is down below